la belle après midi
si la première fois je parle là une
salle que je ne vois pas les gens alors
je vais commencer par vous dire que le
rêve de ma mère était d'avoir des
enfants moyens c'est-à-dire ni trop
grand ni trop petit ni trop beau ni trop
laid mais trop intelligent ni trop idiot
et quand je suis né j'y à exaucer ses
voeux parce que je suis vraiment
moyennes moyennes moyennes est tellement
moyenne que j'ai réussi même à devenir
en fait un caméléon
par exemple quand je vais au japon
chaque fois il ya toujours quelqu'un
un vrai japonais ou une vraie japonaise
qui court après mois pour demander des
informations sur la direction soit le
nom d'une place d'une autre donc le
premier mot que j'ai appris en japonais
s'était étonné me jean desse savent
c'est à dire je suis vietnamienne et je
ne peux pas vous répondre et je ne sais
pas trop comment mais mon corps adopte
très rapidement la posture du japonais
par exemple pour les femmes de marché
avec les pieds un peu pointé vers
l'intérieur
les épaules un peu plus fermé et en
faisant des plus petits pas et tout ça
de façon vraiment je vous dirais
inconscient et puis quand j'étais
avocate et qu'on allait faire des
rencontres en chine dans la salle
j'entends tout le temps quelqu'un
demandé mais où est la canadienne parce
que dans la liste il ya toujours une
canadienne puis on me prenait vraiment
pour une chinoise au vietnam
si vous allez à saigon il ya au moins
deux millions de visages juste dans la
ville de saigon de 10 millions des
visages très semblable au mien
donc je suis vraiment ordinaire
ordinaire ordinaire et puis là j'ai été
élevé en fait pour mener une vie aussi
12 qu'un long fleuve tranquille
malgré que malgré de la guerre qui
déchirait le vietnam à cette époque là
donc 1968 l'année de ma naissance était
également
l'année qui marquait un tournant dans la
guerre du vietnam entre le nord et le
sud le non était soutenu par les
soviétiques et puis le sud n'était
soutenue par les américains et la guerre
était sanglant des videmment mais moi
j'avais la chance aussi non la with a
chance d'être préservé de tout ce chaos
à l'intérieur d'une tour d'ivoire et
c'est seulement quand la paix qui est
arrivé en 1975 que le que l'équilibré a
été perdu et que nous sommes devenus
différents est différent ce sens qu'on
faisait partie du côté des perdants
donc quand le régime du nord le régime
communiste s'est installée dans le sud
on était si vous voulez ciblées et
persécuté évidemment les expériences du
quotidien était très difficile non pas
seulement pour nous mais pour toute la
population par exemple il y avait la
confiscation des maisons dans notre cas
on a donné la moitié de la maison il ya
des soldats qui sont venus habiter avec
nous et aussi toute la nourriture
étaient rationnés
la disponibilité des denrées devenait
très très rare et je vous dirais le
maître ce qui était le plus difficile
dans tout ça c'était l'accès à
l'éducation et l'accès à l'éducation
pourquoi c'était aussi la raison pour
laquelle on a quitté le vietnam et
l'accès à l'éducation c'est qu'à cette
époque là si vous étiez un garçon et que
vous aviez 18 ans et pas admis à
l'université vous allez on s'était
envoyé directement sur un champ de
bataille et chez moi mais j'avais j'ai
deux frères et un oncle qui avait 17 ans
cette époque-là on savait qu'il n'allait
jamais être admis à l'université parce
que les critères d'admission n'était pas
basé sur le mérite
mais sur le l'historique familial et
dans notre cas étant donné qu'on faisait
partie du du régime de l'ancien régime
dont du côté perdant
on savait très bien qu'il allait être
envoyée sur un champ de bataille et
normalement
quand on allait sur une jambe happée on
ne revenait pas et est donc mes parents
ne voyait pas comment on pouvait perdre
tous les garçons dans la famille et donc
ont commencé à réfléchir à acquitter
vietnam et le vietnam était complètement
fermés au monde extérieur c'est en
parler du rideau de fer sur vidéo là
existaient réellement et dont il y avait
plus de libre circulation au civil ils
ont le droit à la libre circulation dont
il y avait plus de vols commerciaux
c'était impossible de même circuler à
l'intérieur du pays
la seule façon de s'enfuir du vietnam de
quitter le vietnam c'était de son furent
par bateau et est donc elle a proposé à
ma grand-mère de laisser mon oncle venir
avec nous et dans les anciennes maisons
envoyer les trous de serrure était
réellement des trous donc on pouvait
voir à travers et pour on pouvait
entendre à travers ces trous de serrure
et ma cousine et moi on a eu la chance
d'être à la maison
cette journée là et on a pu écouter à
travers le trou de serrure
la conversation entre ma mère et ma
grand-mère et ma mère disait proposé à
ma grand-mère de laisser partir et ma
grand mère a dit non tu vas tu es mon
fils parce que elle savait déjà que la
plupart des bateaux qui quittait vietnam
coulé en mer et ma mère est là dit elle
lui a dit écoute ton fils il est déjà
mort
je te demande seulement de choisir
l'endroit où il va mourir est ce que tu
veux qu'ils meurent sur un champ de
bataille ou en mer mais en mer on avait
la chance peut-être le 1% de survivre
est peut-être avoir une deuxième chance
et on fait partie des chanceux je vous
dirais qu'ils qui ont amerri en malaisie
parce que la plupart des bateaux soit
coulé sur traverser
traverser la mer avait beaucoup de
difficultés dans notre cas c'était
seulement quatre jours trois nuits on
était 2 118 personnes sur un bateau je
vous dirais d' un peu plus de 2 mètres
par 6 m et alors que mon oncle qui a
quitté un peu après nous ils avaient
passé plusieurs semaines en mer
et puis après ils ont rencontré des
pirates à sept reprises et rencontrer
des pirates voulaient dire des vols mais
aussi des viols collectifs pour les
femmes
donc nous on a beaucoup de chance parce
qu'on est passé à travers en quatre
jours et sans rencontrer un seul bateau
pirate est arrivé en malaisie on a un
qui est un nouveau statut et le nouveau
statut était d'être des réfugiés est un
réfugié je voudrais être très différents
des humains en ce sens où les réfugiés
sont des gens qui ont été expulsés au
éjectés de leur passé sans avoir été
projeté dans un futur et puis leur
présente devient vide de sens en fait et
si vous regardez les réfugiés il ya un
dénominateur commun nous avons tous à
peu près ce même regard égaré ou sinon
perdue et donc nous étions six réfugiés
et aussi on a écrit un autre
notre qualification nous sommes devenus
des apatrides
on n'appartient plus on appartenait plus
à aucun pays est aujourd'hui évidemment
je suis très fier d'avoir été 100 pays
parce que ça nous arrive jamais on
appartient toujours à une frontière un
pays quelconque alors que nous on a eu
la chance d'être même d'être à personne
pendant quatre mois et est donc au bout
de quatre mois ce qui est un temps très
court
en comparaison avec les autres j'ai
rencontré
un réfugiée vietnamienne justement qui
était dans un camp pendant pendant douze
ans avant d'arriver au canada donc ont
été sélectionnés par le canada et quand
on est arrivé ici je vous dirais là on a
vécu une différence de taille d'abord
vraiment de taille en ce sens d'où tout
le monde était tellement grand et nous
on est maigrichon tout-petits rachitique
a et b d'un camp de réfugiés et et on
nous a emmenés à grand baie parce qu'on
n'avait pas choisi une vivement qu'on ne
connaissait pas on penser que le canada
c'était l'hiver 12 mois par année et
qu'on allait habiter dans un igloo alors
c'était c'était vraiment une grande
surprise mais quoi qu'il y avait
beaucoup de neige à mirabel connaître
effet au mois de mars
non c'était presque une autre planète et
les gens à granby où on est arrivés
étaient tous à la porte de l'autobus
pour me recevoir et tous ces géants nous
ont pris dans leurs bras
mais vraiment et spontanément
immédiatement il n'ya pas il ya eu lui
même pas un moment d'hésitation et je
vous dirais que c'était mon premier choc
culturel parce que 2 1 les asiatiques on
n'est pas trop tactile et puis de deux
ans ça on se savait très sale parce
qu'on n'avait pas accès à l'eau vous
voyez on avait peut-être un litre d'eau
par personne par jour pour manger se
laver boire alors on se savait seul on
savait qu'on avait beaucoup d'infections
sur sur le cas en raison des piqûres de
moustiques de petites bêtes et parce
qu'on dormait directement sur le sol et
et aussi parce que ben voilà il n'y
avait pas d'électricité il y avait il
n'y avait rien dont une était tout
simplement dégueulasse avec les poux
dans les cheveux et ces gens là on ne
comprend pas encore aujourd'hui je ne
comprends pas comment ils ont pu nous
prendre comme ça spontanément dans leurs
bras et je vous dirai évidemment dans le
camp étant donné qu'il n'y avait rien il
n'y avait pas non plus de miroirs dont
je ne mettais pas vu depuis quatre mois
la première fois que je me suis revu
c'était dans le regard de ces gens là et
je vous dirais que et j'aime beaucoup
raconté cette histoire parce que chaque
fois je raconte je revis son moment
et dans le regard je n'avais jamais je
ne m'étais jamais vu aussi belle et je
vous dirais que je ne suis jamais
redevenu aussi belle qu'à ce moment là
et est donc lieu un moment d'amour et on
est tombé vraiment amoureux de les gens
qui nous ont accueillis l'on voulait
devenir québécois et on voulait
embrasser le français avec affection
vous voyez cette époque par par
obligation au parloir par règlement ou
quoi que ce soit on voulait devenir
québécois est allé dans notre première
classe on était huit petits aux
primaires et la prof est venu vers nous
et elle s'est penchée de voir moi
j'étais la première elle a dit je me
marie france et toi et en bonne élève
obéissante alliés tg répéter la même
chose je m'appelle marie france et toi
et voyez à la fin de la journée nous
étions 8 marie france on ne savait pas
évidemment on ne savait pas ce qu'on
sait aussi qu'on disait mais si on le
savait je pense qu'on aurait quand même
accepté de s'appeler marie france parce
qu'on voulait devenir québécois est une
des façons que j'ai trouvé c'était de
changer mon nom mon nom en vietnamien
est oui alors on vient d'amiens tout le
monde m'appelle truies mais en arrivant
ici avec mon nom milieu qui est kim kim
thùy c'est ça le kim est portée par
toutes les filles dans ma famille et
j'ai décidé de laisser tomber thouy et
de prendre king quand je parlais en
français pour effacer un peu l'origine
si vous voulez doudou jeunesse au sinon
la différence et don sweet à utiliser
uniquement en vie un an vietnamien et
mon nom de famille c'était assez
l'hythane et j'ai laissé tomber le tan
pour ne garder que le lit et avec les
âges j'ai découvert un truc c'est
d'ajouter un bep très subtil entre
kimeli pour devenir presque kembo mais
voyez donc quand j'étais avocate et est
après c'était kimblee alors
les personnes qui me parlait la première
fois ils pensaient que j'étais
voilà qui est et dans ses différents
cela a duré très longtemps jusqu'à ce
que ce livre a été écrit
ce premier livre et et pour la première
fois j'ai osé en fait marié les deux
mondes aussi nom fusionné mon nom
vietnamien et puis mon nom québécois
ensemble pour devenu kim tout y est
et aussi parce que probablement de la
maturité d'un permis d'embrasser la
différence et cette différence là elle
m'a beaucoup servi je vous dirais je
pense que si ce livre eu avec moteur
nathalie tremblay probablement que les
journalistes n'auraient pas ouvert mais
parce que c'était kim thùy soirée mais
c'est qui cette fille ou se croit seul
nom et ils ont ouvert et puis tout ce
qu'on espère qu'un journaliste face est
utile d'ouvrir la première page et dont
j'ai vu cette chance là et plus tard je
vous dirais grâce à cette différence
j'ai été invité par le gouverneur
général à faire partie de la première
visite en asie du sud-est première
visite officielle
j'étais une des huit délégués et il ya
un soin on était reçu par le roi de la
malaisie et le jeu et on m'a placé à
côté du juge en chef de la malaisie et
donc il avait ma bio devant lui et sa
tournée il m'a dit comme ça vous avez
été avec 4 j'ai dit oui mais pas
longtemps j'ai cinq ans était alors dite
dans le comment est ce que vous vivez
dans le quotidien la dualité de droit
civil de la commande là au québec
c'était une question je vous dirais ou
difficile pour moi
en fait j'étais très impressionnée que
lui ils connaissent l'histoire du québec
et ses deux systèmes de droit et moi je
ne serai pas comment allonger d'une
bêtise du or vous savez dans le
quotidien on ressent pas du tout la
dualité tout va bien et donc il me
trouvais très bête vers lui
le mât bio il a dit quel est votre rôle
dans cette délégation
parce qu'il commençait à croire que
j'éteigne l'imposteur et j'ai dit vous
savez au canada il ya plusieurs critères
à respecter le premier il faut toujours
avoir une femme dans une délégation j'ai
je suis la femme dans la délégation
et deuxièmement ça prend quelqu'un du
côté francophone je suis francophone
ça prend une minorité visible j'ai en
malaisie je ne suis pas très visible
mais au canada je suis visible
puis troisièmement ça prend quelqu'un en
agriculture et puis dernièrement ça
prend quelqu'un qui a un handicap et
j'ai dit je suis plus petit que tout le
monde au canada gerry challenge est donc
encore mais vite bas on économise
beaucoup d'argent dans ces une chambre
d'hôtel au lieu de cinq
et puis une bouche à nourrir au lieu de
cinq je dois vous avouer qu'on m'a
jamais confirmé qu'elle était le rôle de
mon rôle dans cette délégation là je
crois encore aujourd'hui que j'ai eu la
bonne réponse
j'allais rapporter aux gouvernants
général ils ont tous rient mais ils
m'ont pas répondu
donc j'ai passé dix 10 jours comme ça
être voilà alors à remplir toutes ces
cases et je me suis posé la question en
regardant le titre de la conférence
différend de nature et je me dis
maintenant je suis né vraiment très
ordinaire très moyenne ce sont vraiment
les épreuves de la vie ou s'ils n'ont
pas les épreuves des expériences qui
m'ont rendu différentes
peut-être un peu comme marcel duchamp de
quand il a parlé du dadaïsme de sortir
l'objet de son contexte pour en faire
une offre un objet d'art où il donnait
une autre définition à l'objet et je me
dis j'ai eu la chance d'être sorti de
mon contexte et est soudainement je
deviens un objet un ovni un objet
différent et
et j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
beaucoup de lecteurs et jacques lecteur
va me donner un commentaire différents
par exemple y en a qui dit on devait
lire des livres vraiment pendant deux
heures et puis de la première page la
deuxième page sans sont soulevés y en a
d'autres qui me disent banon de l'est
vraiment une page à la fois ça prend
beaucoup de temps pour absorber ce que
j'écris et puis il y en a un autre qui
dit à ton écriture est tellement légère
a tellement douce et puis il y en a un
autre qui dit tellement violente quand
je dois arrêter après chaque paragraphe
dont chaque lecteur est d'après
exactement les mêmes mots de façon
différente et je me dis que peut-être
que nous ne sommes pas nés différents
nous ne sommes pas différents de nature
mais que c'est l'unicité du mélange des
expériences qui font que qui fait que
nous devenons exceptionnel ou sinon
unique et donc voilà je crois dans mon
cas lorsque je suis la preuve qu'on n'a
pas besoin d'être différent pour être
unique
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]